Fox News pays almost 800 million dollars
to Dominion voting systems because it
was going to get screwed at trial and
while this settlement isn't going to fix
democracy it's definitely going to sting
yes the 2020 election is over and the
winner is well no one three years and
one attempted overthrow of the
government later half the country still
believes that there was major election
fraud that's because conservative media
Outlets like Fox assured them that it
was true over and over and over again
Trump supporters were told that the
election was rigged by a Chinese
Bluetooth thermostats or Italian space
lasers or in the case of dominion voting
systems a Venezuelan algorithm developed
by Hugo Chavez to steal elections thanks
in part to Fox the election tech company
found itself playing a central role in
conspiracy theories vlogged by Donald
Trump about a stolen election local
governments canceled contracts to buy
its voting machines and its employees
found themselves targeted by death
threats in March of 2021 Dominion sued
for defamation and now Fox is cutting a
very very big check how big of a check
well
787.5 million dollars which is about
half of the 1.6 billion dollars that
Dominion asked for when it files you but
remember the amount of money that you
ask for in the prayer in the complaint
is completely arbitrary and always
nonsense that's a whole bunch of libel
slander and it's the kind of settlement
that really shows that fox knew it was
going to get screwed at trial but to
figure out how screwed they were we have
to go back to the start of this lawsuit
in its complaint Dominion pointed to 20
specific segments on Fox which were
defamatory and painted the network as
desperate to claw back its viewers from
upstart conservative Rivals one America
news and Newsmax it started with Fox's
election night call of Arizona for Joe
Biden which provoked an immediate
backlash from the White House Trump's
fail son-in-law Jared Kushner called Fox
CEO Rupert Murdoch directly and Trump
campaign employees began attacking the
company online soon Trump joined the
onslaught firing off a barrage of nasty
tweets about Fox as well as praise for
Newsmax in oan the impact to Fox's
ratings and its stock price was
immediate and it provoked a panic within
the Network's management and so to win
back his viewers fox went on the offense
of giving air time to attorneys like
Sydney Powell and Rudy Giuliani we're
gonna need more air quotes more air
quotes for these attorneys two tell lies
about vote fraud in general and Dominion
in particular Fox host Maria Bartiromo
led the charge on November 8th the
Network's own researchers had been
predicting for weeks that Trump would
lead in early counts of in-person
election day voters but lose ground as
absentee and mail-in ballots were
counted late at night the so-called red
Mirage but after the election Fox
allowed Powell on the air to claim that
Dominion software was corrupted by a
vote flipping algorithm and the
so-called Kraken lawyer claimed that
Trump's Landslide Victory overwhelmed
the servers forcing officials to shut
down the machines in the middle of the
night for dumps of votes for Biden she
even went so far as to accuse Dominion
of bribing election officials in Georgia
the company's complaint accused Fox of
publishing 20 false and defamatory
statements quote to make profit at
Dominion's expense and at the expense of
of the truth they went further saying
quote facing a threat to its most
profitable line of business from other
conservative media Outlets competing for
president Trump's and his supporters
attention Fox knowingly lied about
Dominion in order to keep increase and
win back viewers including its most
important viewer then president Trump
now in May of 2021 Fox filed a motion to
dismiss where the complaint depicted Fox
as a greedy Corporation making a
calculated decision to Airlines to gain
market share the Network's response
described it as a warrior for the First
Amendment quote the Press must remain
free to cover both sides or there will
be a free press no more Fox argued that
Dominion had failed to meet the legal
bar for defamation of a public figure
under the actual mile of Standards
headed by the Supreme Court in the 1964
case of New York Times versus Sullivan a
plaintiff has to prove that the
defendant either knew that the statement
was false or was so reckless in deciding
to publish the information without
investigating whether it was accurate
that it literally did not care whether
the statement was true or false now Fox
alleged that it had no knowledge that
the claims about Dominion rigging the
vote were false when it aired them and
appointed to Trump's allegations about
the widespread fraud and the recount
going on at the time in multiple States
is proof that the stories about vote
dumps and algorithms were inherently
plausible and it also put forward two
specific defenses that are often
confused one is the neutral reportage
defense in which media Outlets are
protected from libel charges when they
accurately and objectively Report
newsworthy claims made by prominent
groups against public figures as part of
an ongoing controversy and similarly the
fair report privilege protects
journalists who accurately quote
statements by public officials or public
documents such as those filed in
litigation but the problem for Fox was
that the state of New York doesn't
recognize the neutral reportage
privilege and the court had already
signaled that it did not find Sydney
Powell's ranting to be a fair report of
any official proceedings and for boring
legal reasons that I won't go into it
does matter what New York state allows
even though this lawsuit was handled in
Delaware so in December of 2021 Delaware
Superior Court Judge Eric Davis denied
Fox's motion to dismiss in a ruling
which should have struck fear in the
hearts of the Network's lawyers now it's
important to note that courts are
obligated to treat all reasonable
allegations as true just for the
purposes of the motion to dismiss but
here the allegations boiled down to a
Sizzle reel of fox clips and there was
no denying that those things actually
happened they didn't just steal the
election from Donald Trump they stole it
from all of you there was a fraud in
their inducement of all things Biden in
order to con you in the city of Detroit
Witnesses have alleged under oath that
ballots were improperly backdated and
counted without matching signatures one
poll Watcher alleges that 40 000 late
unsealed absentee ballots were counted
orally and all of them went for
Democrats we have evidence of how they
flipped the votes how it was designed to
flip the votes and while truth is an
absolute defense to defamation there's
never been a shred of evidence to back
up Trump's fraud claims AP reporters
went looking for cases of voter fraud in
six states that Trump has challenged and
they found fewer than 475 potential
instances out of more than 25 million
votes cast a number that would not have
come close to changing the outcome now
being from Delaware judge Davis said he
wasn't willing to rule as a matter of
New York law whether the neutral
reportage defense would be allowed but
he did note that quote Fox's reporting
must have been neutral not a personal
attack on Dominion to succeed in this
defense and quote Dominion's
well-plitted allegations support the
reasonable inference that Fox's
reporting was not accurate or
dispassionate and as for the fair report
privilege the court noted that the
complaint supported quote the reasonable
inference that Fox's reporting won was
not fair or true and two did not concern
an official proceeding but worst for Fox
was Judge Davis's finding that the
complaint made a colorable case the
quote Fox either one knew its statements
about Dominion's role in election fraud
were false or two had a high degree of
awareness that the statements were false
I.E that they had satisfied the actual
malice standard which is pretty hard to
do the court pointed to quote
countervailing evidence of election
fraud from the Department of Justice
election experts and even multiple
Foster reporters who accurately debunked
the fraud claims on air Joe Biden will
be inaugurated on January 20th to say
this constitutes living in reality
and if I offered you a false reality if
I told you that there was an excellent
phenomenal chance at the Supreme Court
was going to step in and deliver a
victory to president Trump
I'd be lying to you moreover Dominion
plastered Fox with upwards of 3300
emails explaining that the vote reading
claims about its machines were lies
judge Davis wrote the fact that despite
this evidence Fox continues to publish
his allegations against Dominion
suggested Fox knew the allegations were
probably false and so with a motion to
dismiss denied the case continued and
the party spent over a year conducting
Discovery and Dominion's lawyers spent
hundreds of hours deposing every host
producer and executive at Fox that's one
of the reasons these kind of lawsuits
settle early is because you don't want
to get into this kind of extensive
Discovery and here they poured over
thousands of pages of texts and emails
they watched a whole lot of fox clips
and at the end of the year they came
back and filed a motion for summary
judgment in January of 2023. essentially
Dominion argued that there were no
issues of fact everyone agreed what the
factual issues were and it was just up
to the judge to decide the legal
implication of those facts or at least
the outcome of several of the main
issues and the judge judge Davis should
rule on those issues or the entirety of
the case without a trial now this is an
extremely normal thing to do it's
basically a trial on paper but it's also
one of the most labor-intensive motions
that you can file in front of the court
and honestly most of the time these
things don't work but remember Dominion
had been collecting evidence for a year
so while it was trying to persuade the
court to rule in its favor it was also
hoping to show Fox how unpleasant it
would be to actually take this case to
trial The Hope was to inflict enough
pain by putting embarrassing stuff out
in the public that would convince Fox to
settle the case and most people don't
know this but basically everything in
litigation is public unless the judge
seals that evidence which is very very
rare so all of this stuff could enter
into the public domain and Dominion's
motion presented Evans confirming what
it had alleged a year before about Fox
Executives flipping out over the
backlash to their accurate report that
Biden had won Arizona for example from
executive Rod Shaw to CEO Suzanne Smith
quote lots of conservative criticism of
the AZ call the next day Fox's chief
White House correspondent confirmed
quote we are taking major heat over the
AZ call our viewers are also chanting
Fox News Sucks something I have never
heard before
and they're actually chanting Fox News
Sucks another internal message read holy
cow our audience is bad at the network
they're Furious on November 6 FOX
Executives made the decision to cancel
Janine pirro's show to prevent her from
spreading conspiracy theories about the
election fraud executive David Clark
admitted quote her guests are all going
to say the election is being stolen and
if she pushes back at all it will just
be token a producer Justin Wells
confirmed quote they took her off
because she was being crazy Optics are
bad but she is crazy by November 9th
after the election had been called
management at Fox were in a panic over
the backlash to Fox's Arizona call
Tucker Carlson told CEO Suzanne Scott
quote I've never seen a reaction like
this to any Media Company kills me to
watch it Scott complained to her team
about quote the impacts to the brand and
the arrogance and calling Arizona she
texted Lachlan Murdoch quote viewers are
going through the five stages of grief
it's a question of trust the AZ call was
damaging but we will highlight Our Stars
and plant Flags letting the viewers know
we hear them and respect them to which
he agreed to the plan quote yes but
needs constant rebuilding without any
missteps quote yes today is day one and
it's a process but that process did not
include telling the truth to Fox viewers
that same day Fox rebuked Neil Cavuto
for fact-checking false claims about
election fraud made by press secretary
Kaylee mcinany the next day Scott and
Fox News president Jay Wallace traded
messages acknowledging that newsmax's
Embrace of lies about election fraud
were eating into Fox's market share
quote the Newsmax surge is a bit
troubling truly is an alternative
Universe when you watch but it can't be
ignored trying to get everyone to
comprehend we are on war footing yeah
sometimes even the best lawyers have
trouble representing bad clients and as
you probably know finding a great lawyer
can be really hard until now my firm the
eagle team is now accepting the new
clients if you've ever been injured or
just need a lawyer we can represent you
or help you find the right attorney
because you don't need a legal team you
need the eagle team so just check out
the link in the description for that but
back to the Dominion Saga Dominion went
out of its way to prove that it could
inflict a lot of pain on everyone at the
network it revealed private chats
between Fox Stars Tucker Carlson Sean
Hannity and Laura Ingram in which they
railed against the straight news side
for alienating the audience with fact
checks quote in one week and one debate
they destroyed a brand that took 25
years to build and the damage is
incalculable Carlson agreed it's
vandalism
after Fox White House reporter Jackie
Henrik put out a tweet fact checking
election fraud claims Tucker Carlson
complained to the group chat quote
please get her fired seriously it needs
to stop immediately like tonight it's
measurably hurting the company the stock
price is down not a joke but while the
tax disclosures were embarrassing that
fox knew that the fraud claims were
false was worse because to prove
defamation of a public figure like
Dominion in this case you have to prove
that the speaker was at least
indifferent as to the truth of the
statement and in addition to the
internal Communications there was also
the evidence that they used in support
for example Fox house Maria Bartiromo
put Sydney Powell on the air on November
7th and Powell sent her email from the
source of her claims about election
fraud and false allegations about
speaker Nancy Pelosi and Senator Dianne
Feinstein The Source wrote quote I've
had the strangest dreams since I was a
little girl most were just odd others
were clearly predictions I see what
others don't see and hear what others
don't hear and taking a tip from a
source who claims Antonin Scalia was
killed as part of a human Hunting Party
seems pretty indifferent at best between
that and the 3600 plus emails from
Dominion fact checking Fox's false
claims and begging the network to stop
airing them Dominion made a convincing
case that fox had defamed it under the
Sullivan standard so on March 22nd judge
Davis issued a partial summary judgment
in favor of dominion while he wasn't
prepared to rule on the issue of actual
malice he held that each and every one
of the 20 statements pointed out by
Dominion was in fact defamatory which is
a large part of the ball game he said
quote the evidence developed in this
civil proceeding demonstrates that it is
crystal clear that none of the
statements relating to Dominion about
the 2020 election are true you know when
a judge writes in all caps that it's
Crystal Clear that's a bad sign or as he
put it elsewhere in the order quote Fox
takes a nuanced approach to falsity
honestly I think I want that on a
T-shirt and so after this partial
summary judgment in Dominion's favor the
only live issues to be taking care of at
trial were actual malice the extent of
Dominion's damages and whether the fox
Corporation the parent company Fox News
would also be liable for those damages
and the court also released a mountain
of exhibits prepared by Dominion that
showed Fox Executives appearing to
acknowledge that they had aired false
claims about Dominion in one hilarious
email on December 11th it appears to
have dawned on Fox's legal team that
they were about to get sued quote we
need to look at all the times Rudy
Giuliani Sidney Powell Alan dershowitz
and Rona McDaniel came on fnc fbn and
addressed the questions that were raised
about Dominion voting and smartmatic
machines the potential legal dispute is
claiming that we did challenge The
Narrative being put out by Giuliani
Powell at all that the Dominion vote
machines slash smartmatic were
responsible for switching votes and or
producing inaccurate results sometimes
we didn't but we're looking for the
times we did challenge this narrative in
a moment of Lucidity the Frantic
executive added quote it won't be shows
like Dobbs Hannity Etc we need to
specifically look at straighter news
shows there was also a slide Deck with
image after image of Executives saying
things like quote I watched Lou Dobbs
closely for two weeks during the
conventions the North Koreans do a more
nuanced show
the unkindest cuts come from the inside
I guess or Suzanne Scott angrily
emailing her team about fact checks by
Fox host quote this has to stop now this
is bad business the audience is just
furious and we are feeding them material
but still Fox didn't settle so Dominion
applied more pressure in the lead-up to
the April 17th trial date although Fox
definitely helped on April 11th it
emerged in a hearing that Fox's lawyers
had obfuscated Rupert Murdoch's role at
Fox News while the Murdoch family
patriarch is the CEO of Fox Corporation
it was only last week that it emerged
that he also holds a position at Fox
News this was significant because the
issues of actual malice and the
potential liability of the parent
company and judge Davis was not amused
he said quote you have a credibility
problem I need to feel comfortable that
when you represent something to me it's
the truth and this was not true then
Maria bartiromo's former producer Abby
grossberg who was suing the network for
employment discrimination released audio
tapes which she claimed to have turned
over to Fox's lawyers here's Bartiromo
talking to Rudy Giuliani who admits that
he doesn't have proof of the claims he's
making on air whatever you can tell
us
perfect and um
about this software this Dominion
software that was absolutely
to tell you right it's being it's being
analyzed right now I mean there are a
couple of races that have been reversed
because uh the Democrat was Triple
counted two two already in Michigan now
whether that applies for the whole state
or not I can't tell you yet this
convenience software does Nancy Pelosi
have an interest in it yeah I've read
that I don't I can't prove that okay
after Dominion's lawyers play that tape
in court judge Davis ordered Fox's
lawyers to preserve their Communications
regarding the discovery failures and
appoint a special Master to look into
what happened just more pain so on
Sunday April 16th the court announced
that the trial would be delayed by a day
then on Tuesday afternoon when opening
arguments were scheduled to begin they
didn't at 4 pm judge Davis announced the
parties had settled the case and
dismissed the jury on the courthouse
steps Dominion's lawyer Justin Nelson
announced the 787.5 million dollar
settlement roughly half of the 1.6
billion dollars the Dominion had
originally sought Fox put out a pep
statement acknowledging quote the
Court's really finding certain claims
about Dominion to be false and touting
is quote continued commitment to the
highest journalistic standards it did
not admit wrongdoing and so far no one
of the network appears to have gotten
fired you're fired so who won this case
well definitely not Fox despite the fact
that the settlement doesn't require them
to publicly admit wrongdoing on air or
change its behavior in any way 787
million dollars is a huge figure even
for a company as rich as Fox and for
Dominion which was valued at about 80
million dollars in 2018 and might
possibly be around 220 million dollars
in 2022 for the entire company it's an
astronomical payout and yes it could
have gotten more if it had taken the
case to the jury or it might have gotten
nothing and even if it had won the trial
that might have gotten reversed on
appeal so do you know how juries are you
never know and on top of that in any
event any decision would have been tied
up in appeals for years whether they
ultimately won the appeal or not with a
settlement Dominion gets the cash today
and if you're hoping for a corporation
to save American democracy by taking out
another corporation uh well you're going
to be waiting a very long time and while
the public didn't get to spend six weeks
watching dominions lawyers tear apart
the murdochs and hosts like Bartiromo
and Carlson on the witness stand which
admittedly would have been very
entertaining we still got a pretty good
look inside the company and those
statements were found as a matter of law
to be false and in the meantime
Dominion's competitor smartmatic is also
suing Fox for 2.7 billion dollars and
Promises to pick up where this lawsuit
left off and Dominion still has multiple
pending lawsuits against figures like my
pillow guy Mike Lindell and Newsmax so
don't worry it's still going to be 2020
for a very long time but if you have a
mustache like Mike Lindell you should
probably shave it off which you can do
with today's sponsor Henson shaving now
all of you know me as a beard-wearing
eagle lawyer but there's nothing that'll
get a jury more suspicious of you than
looking unkempt and sloppy so keeping my
neck and cheekbones clean is of utmost
importance or in the summer when I just
shave it all off which is where Henson
comes in for the longest time I was
using razors that have five blades in a
disposable head which work but at the
same time you go through those
cartridges really quickly and they're
insanely expensive but this is the
Henson al-13 a single bladed safety
razor the engineering that went into
this thing is immense the difference is
that instead of five blades this guy
only has one blade and the blades are
super cheap to manufacture and there's
no plastic in the cartridges so they're
better for the environment and it's much
better for your budget and everything
else now I've seen claims that one
bladed safety razors do a better job
because they cut at the surface instead
of getting down below the surface which
can cause irritation and razor bumps but
to be honest I can't tell a difference
which is actually great because you
don't have to spend fifty dollars for a
pack of five bladed cartridges that will
only last a few weeks now this razor is
made using CNC machines to Aerospace
standards and the Razer is really clever
because they designed it in a way that
is idiot proof to make sure that the
blade is seated 13 one thousands of an
inch past the shave plane every time
Henson blades only cost 10 cents so a
Year's worth of Shaving could only cost
three to five dollars but with my promo
code you'll actually get 100 blades free
which could last for years and that's
why I'm not trying to sell you a
subscription hence it just makes good
quality razors so if you decide you want
to invest in a quality safety razor that
works and will be drastically cheaper to
own than the competitors click on the
link that's on screen right now or down
in the description and select which
razor you'd like out of a variety of
different colors then as I said use the
promo code legal eagle and you'll also
get a hundred stainless steel double
edge replacement blades for free so
again click on the link below and use
the promo code legal eagle to get 100
free blades with your purchase and after
that click on this link over here for
more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court